hommage les douloureux souvenirs en ce
samedi pour les américains vingt ans
après les attentats du 11 septembre 2001
qui ont coûté la vie à près de 3000
personnes l'attentât le plus meurtrier
de l'histoire américaine et qui a changé
la face du monde entier ce matin-là
quatre avions ont été détournés par des
terroristes d'al qaïda deux d'entre eux
se sont écrasés sur les tours jumelles
du world trade center un mémorial il ya
été construit depuis c'est ici que la
cérémonie officielle a lieu en ce moment
même une cérémonie présidée par le
président américain joe biden sept
attentats du 11 septembre 2001 on en
parle justement avec le grand reporter
rtl france régis le sommier
agissent bonjour merci d'être avec nous
un plaisir de vous recevoir à sur ce
plateau là vous avez vécu pendant six
ans à new york à partir de 2003 ça veut
dire tout juste deux ans après ce
terrible drame vous avez été témoin de
la façon dont la ville s'est
reconstruite après ces terribles
attentats on peut même dire que new york
s'est relevée finalement grâce à la
résilience des américains alors grâce à
la résilience des new yorkais et surtout
new york n'était pas du tout habitués ce
qu'il faut se rendre contrat avoir une
date dans son histoire parce que l'once
septembre 2001 est arrivé ça a été donc
évidemment la tragédie qu'on connaît
mais pour les new yorkais new york vous
savez c c'est la ville de l'éternel
présent c'est la ville qui est pour
chaque que chaque habitant se projette
vers l'avenir c'est la ville du business
c'est la vie la ville de l'énergie donc
il y avait absolument pas d'idée de
commémoration véritable dans dans
l'univers new yorkais et tout à coup les
new york et se trouve amputée de deux de
leurs principaux
building en fait de 2 2 lors leurs
symboles quelque part et moi j'ai vécu
toutes ces années donc de 2003 à 2009
avec une sorte d'impossibilité pour les
new yorkais jeu qu'on sentait très bien
à savoir comment il fallait commémorer
cette tragédie il y avait ce trou béant
quand on passait à ingrandes 0 il y
avait encore des des gravats etc et les
new yorkais en fête avait commencé à
faire et dès le lendemain du 11
septembre à faire des petits ex voto
avec des photos ton pied des photos de
gens qui étaient morts dans les tours et
il se hisse eux comment dire il se
recueillaient quelque part en tournant
le dos à ce trou béant en regardant ces
photos en regardant ces petites petites
chapelles qu'il y avait tout autour du
trou est en fait pendant très longtemps
il ya eu des batailles d'avocats
terrible avant que la commande le world
trade juan la grande tour roh finalement
rejaillissent et que new york retrouve
une forme même si elle est aujourd'hui
c'est une tour solitaire avant qu avant
c'étaient deux tours et c'était c'était
en fait quelque chose d'assez d'assez
difficile pour les new yorkais alors les
images du world trade center des images
symboliques la figure du world trade
center étaient disposés un peu partout
dans la ville y avait dès l'aube ou
qu'on voyait et si vous voulez pour les
new yorkais y avait quand même cette
difficulté à faire leur deuil d'abord
parce qu'il y avait quand même eu que
deux mille neuf cents personnes qui
étaient mortes dans ces tours c'était
quelque chose de compliqué pour eux à à
cause de cette particularité je pense de
new york et puis l'immensité du crime et
de de l'affront dont il avait été
victime pendant cette période pendant
laquelle vous avez a vécu à new york
vous avez rencontré des proches des
pompiers morts pendant le 11 septembre
des maires des mamans et on imagine
parfaitement que c'est une rencontre
qu'a dû être plein d'émotions oui j'ai
relu ce matin en fait ce papier je me
disais j'ai fouillé un peu de ses
souvenirs de correspondants et c'est
quelque chose qui m'avait beaucoup
marqué parce que on se rend pas bien
compte en fait on parle toujours des
attentats et quand on a vécu un attentat
soi même on imagine bien au bout d'un
moment voilà ça se disperse en réalité
ce qui se passait pour ces mères de
pompiers elle se réunissait tous les
jeudis dans une caserne de staten island
c'est une sorte de rituel qui était venu
y avait un prêtre qui ouvrait avec un
psaume et et ensuite c'est mr passé leur
soirée a raconté leur fils donc elle
avait fait des petites cartes avec
dessus la photo de leur fils la caserne
dans laquelle il avait appartenu et puis
elle racontait elle va en parler alors à
la longue c'était devenu finalement une
sorte de fils idéal qu'elle qu'elle
célébrait et je me souviens
particulièrement d'une
mr qui est arrivé vers moi pour me
donner la photo de son fils elle me
donne une photo quand je la regarde et
puis je fais plus attention hélas elle
revient elle me dit elle me donne une
deuxième photo et me dit non non la sas
et john il est mort dans la tour nord et
ça c'est jim je sais que exactement son
prénom mais lui il est mort dans la tour
sud et je suis resté comme ça devant
cette mère je savais plus quoi dire que
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire à une mère qui
a perdu 27 ans 10 ans la tour nord et à
ses fils dans la tour sud c'est
absolument épouvantable
est ce qu'il faut s'apercevoir c'est que
la plupart de ces mères n'avaient jamais
retrouvé où pratiquement aucune le corps
de leur fils et à l'époque elle
protestait beaucoup parce qu'elle disait
on a retrouvé le corps des terroristes
on a fait des analyses etc tandis que
nos fils ils sont sous un tas de gravats
à staten island là où on avait fait une
sorte de décharge des détritus du world
trade center et et on les reverra jamais
donc une impossibilité totale de faire
le deuil donc une douleur vraiment
vraiment extrême ça m'avait beaucoup
marqué parce que je trouvais que c'était
vraiment symbolique parce que c'était
des gens les pompiers c'est ils en ont
ils sont morts à peu près 300 pompiers
qui sont morts parmi les 3000 personnes
qui ont été tués ce jour là et il y
avait vraiment cette cette dimension de
2,2 l'idée qui s'était qui qui l avait
qu'ils avaient accouru et qu'ils qui
s'étaient sacrifiés sans penser aux
autres aie aie aie aie un sentiment
terrible d'injustice chez ces maires de
ne pas simplement pouvoir retrouver un
voilà une forme matérielle de leur fils
qu on imagine à quel point ça d'être dur
de faire le deuil sont là sans le
cadavre sont la dépouille doit être cher
on a perdu alors on le sait le 11
septembre a eu un impact pour tout le
monde mais pour vous quel a été l'impact
dans votre vie et dans votre carrière de
journaliste à moi ça a été je suis
clairement un fils du 11 septembre c'est
à dire que d'abord c'est le 11 septembre
qui m'a amené à new york c'est à la
suite de cette tragédie plus le
directeur de paris match à l'époque m'a
proposé de venir correspondant à new
york et quand je suis arrivé vous le
soulignez deux ans après
c'était le début de la guerre en irak et
il y avait eu d'abord la guerre en
afghanistan mais une guerre qui s'était
plus ou moins bien déroulé au début
al-qaïda avait été défait le régime des
taliban avaient chuté et est là
l'amérique venait de déclencher une
nouvelle guerre en irak et moi j'arrive
aux états unis et il n'y a pas un papier
où quasiment su que j'écris par semaine
il n'y a pas le mot irak dedans et je me
souviens d'avoir rappelé le directeur de
match à l'époque et je vais lui avoir
dire alain genestar j'avais dit je peux
pas continuer à couvrir l'amérique s'en
aller en irak il ya cent cinquante mille
gi's qui sont en irak il faut qu' il
faut témoigner de ce qu'ils ressentent
là-bas il ya un tel écho cette guerre
est tellement omniprésente pour
l'amérique elle va devenir d'ailleurs un
poids incroyable avec les conséquences
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui le souhait de
retrait l'élection de barack obama n'a
pas été du simplement la belle
personnalité de barack obama lé début un
agenda anti-guerre de barack obama qui
va être suivi par donald trump et on l'a
vu aujourd'hui avec le retrait des
troupes américaines d'afghanistan aussi
donc qu'il ya déjà une lassitude qui se
fait dans la sève dans la société et moi
j'avais observé ça et je vais partir en
irak et ça va être le début de ma
carrière de correspondant enfin en tout
cas de journalistes de guerre puisque
c'est comme ça et voilà donc le 11
septembre a changé ma vie aussi parce
que j'ai témoigné de ses guerres de
l'amérique de ces guerres ce qu'on
appelle les guerres sans fin
et toute cette transformation c'est ce
choc qui a eu lieu entre le monde arabo
musulman et l'amérique à partir du 11
septembre gars enfin on va donc parler
de celle en afghanistan c'est que ces
attentats du 11 septembre ont précipité
à l'intervention un militaire étrangère
en afghanistan mené en tête il y avait
des américains il entre donc dans le
pays il chasse les talibans du pouvoir
il reste vingt ans en afghanistan les
troupes sont toutes parties à la fin de
ce mois d'août ça devait normalement
signer le début
une nouvelle ère finalement c'est ce qui
s'est passé en quelques jours un les
talibans reprennent le pouvoir pourquoi
l'histoire se répète comme cela elle est
terrible elle était aussi terrible il
faut bien le rappeler aussi en irak
puisque 2010 barack obama retire les
troupes américaines d'irak ce n'est pas
le seul paramètre à prendre en compte
mais en tout cas c'est important c'est
le début de l'émergence de dèche
fulgurante qui va conquérir un tiers de
l'irak quasiment est un pays à peu près
de la superficie de l'angleterre à
cheval sur l'irak et la syrie donc le
retrait des troupes américaines d'irak
déjà en 2010 même si son revenu après
même s'ils ont justement chasser des
chais qui a une nouvelle coalition en
2014 a provoqué cette catastrophe là
cette fois ci on l'amérique se trouve à
face à un comment je dirais encore un
une humiliation d'une certaine façon
parce que ce qu'elle a voulu faire en
afghanistan ne s'est pas du tout produit
elle a porté à bout de bras un
gouvernement qui s'est avéré au fil des
années incapable d'être inclusif je sais
que le terme est à la mode aujourd'hui
on se dit les talibans vont ils faire un
gouvernement inclusif en tout cas le
gouvernement précédent n'a pas du tout
été inclusif et en tout cas il n'a pas
dû tout assumer le pouvoir sur
l'ensemble de l'afghanistan ni apporter
des solutions alors on allait dans ces
guerres il faut voir aussi que c'est ce
qui est important c'est que il y avait
des idées préconçues il y avait l'idée
que la démocratie pouvait à condition de
faire tomber les régimes dictatoriaux ou
les douches ou les régimes au régime
taliban par exemple que la démocratie
allait naturellement se répandre dans
ces pays notre démocratie c'est à dire
une façon pour nous de voir la
démocratie sans prendre en compte
réellement les particularités locales
sans prendre en compte les habitudes
aussi de ces pays et en imaginant que
nous étions forcément et les régimes
dans lesquelles nous vivions était
forcément les meilleurs et que ces gens
allaient les accepter en applaudissant
ça ne s'est pas du tout passé comme ça
de force libératrice assez rapidement en
irak et en afghanistan l'amérique est
devenue une force d'occupation comme
d'autres pays avant elle a reçu bill
même sort finalement que l'urss 20 ans
avant et auxi vous dites ne pas répéter
les erreurs de l'histoire c'est je pense
d'abord essayé d'apprendre des guerres
précédentes d'essayer de se dire
finalement est ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de livrer la même guerre qu'il ya
dix ans il ya vingt ans et est ce que
tout ça finalement
neu neu neu n'amène pas justement aux
tragédies qu'on connaît aujourd'hui la
plupart des pays dans lesquels dans
lesquelles ces deux guerres ses droits
ces guerres du droit d'ingérence rond
lieux sont aujourd'hui anéanti
j'ajouterai à cette équation la libye
dont la l'anéantissement à provoquer
l'instabilité au sahel si la france est
présente aujourd'hui au sahel c'est à
cause de cette guerre en libye à cause
d'une guerre finalement on a oui
déboulonner un dictateur mais on a mis
quoi à la place c'est toujours la même
question me souviens de deux d'une
phrase du général petraeus qui a qui a
commandé donc la coalition en irak en
afghanistan pendant longtemps et qui est
un peu une sorte de général éclairé
américain puisqu'il a quand même réussi
à
essayer de changer le cours de la guerre
au moment où elle était pratiquement
perdu et général petraeus disait après
la chute de batte de bail de bagdad de
bagdad dites moi ce qu'il faut faire
c'est à dire qu'est-ce qu'on mais quel
est le plan 4 est en fait le plan 4
c'est de la quatrième phase elle n'avait
jamais été pensé on imaginait ou en tout
cas l'occident dans sa sublime en europe
arrogance imaginait que naturellement
les irakiens à aller comme on peut
remettre en place des élections et que
ces élections allaient conduire à
l'avènement d'un d'un d'un commande un
bon coup d'une puissance démocratique ou
ou de quelque chose qui ressemblerait
globalement à ce qu est l amérique et
c'est ça je pense le problème et c'est
là aujourd'hui où on vient face à
aujourd'hui en afghanistan
des puissances régionales sont à la
manoeuvre elles comblent le vide laissé
par les états unis je pense à la chine
je pense à la turquie je pense à l'iran
également qui arrive aujourd'hui et
déjoue de leur influence en afghanistan
maintenant que l'amérique est parti je
crois aussi que l'amérique donc a
compris que ces guerres du droit
d'ingérence ou seger du messianisme
démocratique ne pouvait plus avoir lieu
donc comme elle l'a fait à l'époque de
donald trump avec une une une chirurgie
savons bien de voir le reportage de
thomas sur steam est ce que vous
comprenez cette volonté d'avoir accès
finalement à tous les dossiers autour de
ces attaques est là en l'occurrence on
sent bien qu'ils aient une direction
vers laquelle veut orienter ce survivant
c'est à dire la question du deuil au
rapport justement entre les saoudiens et
lolë et l'auront septembre en fait
qu'elle n'a été finalement qu'est ce
qu'ils puissent passer autour de ce pays
pourquoi pour une simple raison c'est
que d'abord le commanditaire le chef
c'est ben laden c'est où sa mamelle la
même donc oussama ben laden et saoudiens
même si il faut le rappeler au nombre
des attentats du 11 septembre il n'y a
dit n'avait plus l'avait été déchu de sa
nationalité saoudienne était barrée au
soudan et ensuite il a trouvé refuge il
a fait allégeance au mollah omar en
afghanistan les 19 sur les 19 kamikazes
du 11-septembre je crois de mémoire que
il y en a deux qui l inquiète libanais
et un autre d'une autre nationalité 2
quai mohamed atta qui égyptien les
autres sont yéménites et saoudiens donc
on est on est quand même donc des
pilotes d'ailleurs donc on est quand
même avec une représentation les
saoudiens ont en tout cas de la
péninsule arabique absolument énorme
dans dans la lah la préparation et c'est
des gens qui ont été formés comment
recruter entraîné à kandahar donc sur
une d1 des camps d'al-qaïda avant le 11
septembre et donc voilà donc il y avait
quand même et puis il ya le tout les
relations assez obscur entre les
services de renseignements saoudiens les
talibans d'une part et al qaïda voilà
donc je pense que ce que veulent ce que
veulent ces survivances et ça c'est
faire un petit peu comment l'éclairage
dans tout cas la lumière sur ce qu'elle
a pu être le rôle qu'elles ont et
qu'elles ont pu être
la part finalement prises par un certain
nombre de saoudiens dans ces attentats
et ça ça serait bien en effet on sait
que les haines les etats-unis ont un
rapport particulier avec ce pays pour
tout vous dire j'ai même trouvé ce
discours il ya un mois j'étais donc à
comment en afghanistan où j'ai réalisé
un document ça un documentaire sur les
talibans et un commandant taliban me
disais pourquoi nous avoir attaqué nous
l'afghanistan est pas la patrie
d'oussama ben laden qui venait de là les
kamikazes il venait de là pourquoi vous
avez attaqué l'afghanistan donc c'est
quelque chose qui même trouvé un écho du
côté des talibans en disant voilà vous
avez admis anti notre pays vous êtes
venu nous envahir élèves et l'arabie
saoudite qu'est ce qu'elle a vu rien du
tout d'une certaine façon il ya
peut-être quelque chose à clarifier ce
niveau là qui a toujours pas été fait y
compris pour les autres pays occidentaux
parce que on a toujours des relations un
peu compliqué avec ce pays qui est
évidemment le grand pourvoyeur
d'hydrocarbures dans le monde voilà
réagissent merci pour votre intervention
pour cette journée particulière un
commémoration à des drames du 11
septembre 2001